here is uh the content
of our workshop today as you can see
there are a few chapters but i promise
they will be
short and sweet so we would first by
introducing the definition of a graph
and the basic theories of graph neural
network
as well as some applications
and then we will dive in deeper to
compare different variations
of graph convolution at the end of the
workshop
i will show a small demo to perform node
classification
using stellar graph
okay so first
what is a graph a graph is a set of
nodes connected by
directed or undirected edges where each
node
represents real-world entities and
an edge define a certain type of
relationship between
a pair of entities but moreover
each node may contain information about
the entity
which we define as the initial node
features
and usually they are represented by a
fixed size vector
so in the case of neural network in the
case of social network
node features can nodes
represent users and node features can be
personal attributes like age gender
locations and so on
but beside a social network there are
many other types of data that can be
represented as graph
like molecules or transportation network
etc
so yeah as we know that
most of the popular deep learning
frameworks
work really well with images and
sequences
that can be represented by fixed size
vectors or
matrices but graph
is a bit more unstructured in comparison
in the sense that a graph contains
arbitrary
number of nodes with arbitrary number of
connections
and there is no fixed ordering of data
points
for it to be modeled as a sequence so is
there a machine learning model that
can work efficiently on graphs and
the answer is yes surprise surprise it's
code graph neural networks so graph
neural network is
a set of deep learning models that can
be
directly applied to graphs
it is introduced back in 2005
but they started to gain popularity in
the last five years
due to their versatility to suit any
type of problems
they work based on the idea that nodes
so entities in a graph can be
contextualized
by the features of all the entities that
they are associated with
just like how tokens in a sequence of
texts can be contextualized by its
surrounding words
so the goal of a graphing neural network
is to compute a node representation
that encodes its initial features as
well as
its connections and this node
representation
is represented as a fixed size vector
like
hv and by
leveraging the rich information from hv
we can build much more accurate models
for
different types of tasks
generally speaking the real world
applications
based on graph neural networks can be
categorized into the following groups
so the first one and the most common one
is node classification this is
when we classify the label of a node
provided its node features and its
connections
so for example uh in a social network
given
this person's personal attributes
and their his or her connections
you may predict if this person belongs
to a certain community or has a certain
political leaning for example
you can also kind of transit from
a node level classification to a graph
level classification
by combining the node embedding from all
the
from the targeted region so in this case
you are classifying an attribute about a
group of users
but and the third one is link prediction
that's when given two nodes that are
unassociated we estimate the probability
that they
could be linked so commonly used in
front recommendation
and graph similarity is when we compute
the similarity between the graph
structure
and this is really useful in the context
of
white lab where the hyperlink network
of a website can be represented as graph
and given a website you could make
recommendations
on a list of websites that have similar
hyperlink structure
and according to this paper it also
helps you to identify websites
or resources that is the most
authoritative
and graph generation has been the hot
direction
in the context of drug discovery
basically compounds can be represented
as graph
where the nodes represent atoms
and edges represent a certain type of
bond
and in this paper they are generating
uh chemicals with desired properties
using a two floor generation model so
yeah it's kind of cool
last but not least gnn has been really
influential
tonight especially when it comes to
website
representation learning and essentially
web pages can be represented as graphs
so we can apply some of those
graph-based techniques to contextualize
parts of the page which allows our model
to navigate through the site
like a human so
in summary gnn can be suitable for
problems in a wide range of domains
and i just found out that yesterday gnn
can also be used
in quantum computing um i hardly
understood anything from that paper
but it's kind of mind-blowing
right so back to the basic
let's understand how gnn work
specifically
how does gnn learn the embedding from
the graph neighborhood
so it aggregates the features of
the neighboring nodes using a special
operator
which is what we call a graph
convolution operator
so let's first think of a
image convolution they kind of exploit
the fact that images have a
regular connectivity pattern so
by that i mean each pixel can be
surrounded by eight other pixels
it aggregates the neighborhood pixels by
applying kernel filters of fixed size
and graph convolutions are kind of
similar except
it aggregates any number of node
features
so specifically given the target node
it aggregates the information from each
of its neighboring nodes
up to a certain search depth
and also just like image kernels it can
be both
non-parametric like mean pooling
or it can consist of some learnable
weights
which you will see in in the later
slides
so there are many variations
of graph convolution but typically they
can
fall into two categories they're
spectral
and spatial based so in the next
couple of slides i will explain the
differences between them
and you will see that spatial is a much
more
efficient and scalable approach than
spectral
is everyone following so far
any questions
all right i'm gonna dive in deeper to
understand uh the difference between
spectral and spatial graph convolution
so the first generations of graph
convolution were spectral based
and they have a theoretical foundation
in
graph signal processing so it treats
the operation as removing noises from
the graph signals that is the node
features
it basically operates on the entire
graph all
at once followed by a series of really
complex linear
operations in order to obtain h
and h is a matrix that represents
the final node embedding for all the
nodes in this class
and on the other hand oh sorry before i
move on
h k represents the node embedding
after applying uh the
convolution layer for the case time
but moving on spatial based approach
however operates on one node or a batch
of nodes
at a time it does so by learning an
aggregated function to aggregate the
information from neighborhood
to the target node
and this is the expression after one
convolution layer right don't worry if
this doesn't make sense to you initially
i will work through an example to
illustrate this in detail
so this is our example graph and as you
can see
spectral generates the laplacian using
this
this formula and then it normalizes the
laplacian matrix
which is then followed by an eigen
decomposition
of this laplacian matrix to obtain a set
of orthonormal
eigenbases and then it
performs fourier transformation of the
node features
and g here represents a set of learnable
weights
and basically many many complicated
math operations and we don't need to
worry about that
so eventually you would arrive at this
expression
but seriously do not worry because you
will see why
spectro is no longer a preferred
approach
so when it comes to spatial
it operates the aggregation on one node
at a time so for example uh
first at node 1 we will aggregate
the information from node 2 and node 3
as well as the initial features from
node 1
to obtain a updated node embedding for
node one
and we would repeat this for all the
nodes in this graph
and this counts as one convolution layer
so essentially you could just initialize
the embedding for all the nodes in this
graph to be their initial node features
you repeat this convolution for a number
of times
in order to get their final
embedding for each of the nodes in this
graph
so let's do a thorough comparison in
terms of application
spectral models as you can see
operates on the whole graph so it
suffers from
some drawbacks in terms of scalability
it requires the whole graph to be
processed simultaneously
so this can be very impractical for
large graphs
that contains billions of nodes and
edges such as a social network
whereas spatial do not suffer from the
scalability
issue because they directly perform
convolution
on a neighborhood basis so
together you can also incorporate some
sampling strategy
the computation can be performed in a
batch of nodes
instead of a whole graph so it can be
done
in parallel which improves
efficiency for training
and the biggest limitation for spectral
is the fact that it cannot generalize to
unseen graph so any change that you make
to this graph will result in a change
of the laplacian representation so
this means that if you change the eigen
basis and everything you need to retrain
the weights
therefore it can be impractical for
graphs that
constantly evolves or changes
whereas spatial on the other hand can be
generalized to unseen graphs quite
easily
because the aggregated weights can
induce
the embedding of unsignals based on the
structure
and on top of that spatial based models
are flexible
they can handle graphs with different
structures
like graphs with multiple edge or node
types
and because because these variations of
the graph input can be
incorporated into the aggregation
function
right and going back to the algorithms
of
these two approach we see that both
of them involve applying the convolution
layer repetitively
repeatedly sorry my english repeatedly
and the intuition for this is that every
time we apply
the aggregation layer we would propagate
the information
up to one hop so the more layers you
apply
the further the information gets
propagated from its source node
therefore the richer your final
embedding would become
okay having introduced spatial
convolution
i am going to now introduce to you
uh two of the most popular frameworks
for
spatial convolution which is graph sage
and
graph attention networks so first we
have graph sage
graph stage is a really popular model
that is
used for inductive learning on large
graphs
so like we introduced earlier it learns
aggregator function that can induce the
embedding of a new node
given its features and neighborhood and
it trains
an aggregator function to aggregate
neighbors at different search steps and
specifically what do we mean by
aggregator function
it is a function that accepts
neighborhood as input
so specifically a set of node embeddings
from the neighborhood
and combine the embedding to create
a neighborhood aware node embedding for
the target node
as you know that the node's neighbors
should have no
natural ordering so an aggregate data
function should be invariant
to the node ordering or permutations
and aggregate function can be both
non-parametric
such as mean pooling or max pooling
or it can be a parametric so it can
contain learnable weights like a simple
neural network
the most popular one the most popular
learnable
aggregator is a single layer neural
network followed by max pooling operator
you could also use lstm where you would
feed
the node representation from the
neighborhood
as a sequence but you need to randomly
shuffle the order
so that your model can learn with
without overfitting to a certain order
and the propagation step which is
uh the embedding generation step for
graph stage
is really similar to what we've have
seen earlier
in a spatial convolution so first you
would initialize
the node embedding in this graph to be
the initial
features then you apply multiple
convolutions
where you aggregate for each node you
aggregate
the features from its neighbors
then you concatenate this neighborhood
features with the features of the node
and in the end you normalize it you
normalize the
final embedding
and yeah and you obtain
zb which is the final representation
for your target node
i've broken these down into those little
boxes
but essentially graph stage in a
nutshell
is simply just those four steps
right moving on to
training so how do we train a graph sage
you can train it in a both supervised
learning and unsupervised learning
setting
so in a supervised learning uh you may
train it to minimize the cross-entropy
loss
and in the unsupervised learning where
you don't train with labels
you train with the assumption that um
nodes which reside the same neighborhood
should have
similar embedding like this and nodes
that are independent
should be far away from each other in
the embedding space
and you could uh achieve this by
minimizing this loss
so jju
defines the loss at node u
and v is a neighbor of u
p n this should be p and u is the
negative
sampling for you so that it's a sample
of
nodes that are not in used neighborhoods
so you could break this loss
into two parts the by minimizing the the
first part of the loss
you maximize the similarity so the inner
product between
uh the embedding of you and the
embedding of b
and similarly the second part
uh by minimizing the second part of the
loss
you minimize the similarity between
z u and this independent
node
so having seen the theory of brass sage
i would like to introduce an application
for it
which is used by pinterest for post
recommendation
they adapted the algorithm for graph
stage
into their own framework called pinsage
where it uses an important and
important based neighborhood sampling
with random work so that
nodes with the highest visit counts
will have highest weights in the
aggregation step
so they contribute more to the final
node representation but alternatively
you can also use attention mechanism to
determine the importance of neighbors
so this brings us to the next variation
of graph convolution which is
graph attention network
so like i mentioned earlier a graph
attention network
computes a sort of attention coefficient
of each of the neighbor nodes when it
comes to neighborhood aggregation
so that the your node representation
becomes a well a direct can be derived
basically
from a linear combination of the
neighborhood features like this
they are weighted by those attention
coefficients
alpha so alpha i j here
represents the
importance of node j when aggregating
information
for the target node i and alpha
is computed using an attention mechanism
that is represented by the function a
furthermore uh jt applies the multi-hat
attention
uh for better expressive ability so
for example um here we have three
attention heads
and each attention head computes um
an equivalent expression like the one
you see here
but each attention head use different
sets of
weights and in the end
the features from all the attention
heads are averaged
to obtain the final representation
and here i included a slide to explain
how the attention mechanism works
but due to time concerns i will skip
this for now but if anyone
is interested to know more about it feel
free to ask me at the end of the
workshop
to wrap things up uh here's a short
summary on
the theory we've covered so far on gns
so we have seen that spatial approaches
are
more desirable for learning large graphs
due to the fact that they are more
computationally efficient
and they have better generality and
better flexibility
we also covered two of the popular
spatial frameworks
graph sage that uses
aggregator functions and you can
incorporate sampling
to assign importance to neighbors
while a graphic tension network use
multi-hat attention
for neighborhood importance
okay i'm about to move on to the
application part
so since graph has gained a lot of
attention in research
and applications there are a couple of
really well developed gnn packages for
python
my personal experience i've used pytorch
geometric
which is a graph deep learning extension
library for pytorch
and i have used a stellar graph that is
built on tensorflow and keras
both of these packages contain
a huge variety of graph models and a lot
of
common benchmark data sets for you to
explore
while i recommend both of them i found
stella
much easier to learn for beginners so in
the next 10 minutes
i will walk you through a node
classification example
using stellar graph and
this node classification task is
performed on
a citation network data set
so this citation network data set
consists of one citation
graph and this graph contains uh
roughly 3000 publications
and they're all classified into seven
subjects as such
this network consists of over 5000
links and each publication in the data
set
has an initial feature of
1400 and this feature is derived
from a dictionary depending on uh
if those words from dictionary are
contained in the publication
right so the goal of this node
classification task
is to classify the subject of the paper
given
its initial vocabulary features and its
citation connections
and then we would also like to explore
whether or not
incorporating graph structure can help
with node classification so we will
compare
a simple neural network as a baseline
model
with graph sage and gat
here is the experiment setup for this
demo
and to keep a fair test all the node
subjects are
split in this proportion
there's a standard value of dropout
applied to other models
and they're all trained to minimize the
cross entropy loss
and to evaluate the performance of our
models we will
mainly be using test accuracy but we
will also
use a qualitative approach where we
assess
the structure of the embedding using
disney plots in 2d
and to help you to get an idea on
the initial embedding this is the disney
visualization
of the initial vocab embedding for all
the publications
and they are colored by their ground
truth subject
so yeah it looks like a big hop a big
hot mess
so let's see if applying some graph
models
can help the representation become more
structured and
more meaningful okay
i'm going to get my scripts ready
for the demo
just bear with me
all right
so this is um python
and i will be running my experiments
in those two main scripts here
so the first one is a train baseline
which trains my baseline model and the
second one
uh trains the graph of neural network
models so graph sage and gat
those two scripts are structured in a
similar way
so first we we get the
data set from cora
we get the features from the graph
followed by finalizing the
the target labels into one hot vectors
right and then we would perform the
train test split
on the data set and here i build my
baseline model
which is simply a two layer neural
network
and then i train it and evaluate it on
the test nodes
okay so let me run this to get the
baseline results
okay now i'm
let's look at the graph uh the graph
training script
so like like the baseline script um
it kind of has the same structure except
here
we built we built the model
using grass agent gt
imported from stellar graph
we also built a generator
that generates a batch of nodes and
their connections at training time
so we don't have to train on the whole
graph at once
and let's look closely in the models
so here my graph stage model consists of
two convolution layers
each producing an output of 32
dimensions
and my graph extension networks
also consist of two convolution layers
but it uses eight attention heads
right so both of these graph models
output a final embedding for each of the
notes
so we stack a prediction layer on top of
the embedding
to output the label
and after we define our model and our
generator
we create the generator flows
based on the training validation and
test
data set
okay and then we can just train the
graph model
like using model.fit
just like how you would train any other
keras deep learning model but this time
we are using
the training generator flow instead of
the training data set
okay
and uh one thing to also to mention is
that
when we visualize the embedding of our
model
i am taking uh the final
layer from the graph models so that is
the layer right before soft max
as the embedding layer
okay oh
i didn't realize the results for the
baseline is is
finished okay so let's see
first this is the disney visualization
for the embedding from uh the baseline
model
so the data points looks kind of
segmented
but still with a lot of overlap
and the test accuracy is roughly 62
it's not so bad okay
let's see if graphs can do better
oh no this one the other one
okay so right now i am training uh the
graph
attention networks for the same number
of epochs
as the baseline model
okay so the test accuracy is 77
which is a significant improvement to
the to the first one
and here is the disney visualization for
the graph
attention networks embedding and as you
can see there
seems to be some clear clusters being
formed
so yeah it's a pretty good
it's a pretty good embedding space okay
let's try graph sage
so what was the one you just ran the
graph attention
oh yeah
so right now i'm getting rough attention
um hmm i really don't know at this point
why not it should be because it contains
eight heads
so the information that it can encode
should be very rich
and i also see that actually um graph
attention
uh is doing pretty well in terms of not
over fitting to
the training data in comparison to the
baseline
so yeah okay so there we have our graph
sage test accuracy which is
79 percent slightly higher than
um graph attention for some reason
okay and here is the t-sne versus
visualization of the graph staging
bedding
it looks very well structured i couldn't
tell which one is better
but yeah
this is the end of the demo
so it's graph neural network is not a
myth
it actually works in real life
am i still sharing my screen whoops
no okay
right let me just to wrap it up
okay can you see my screen
yes okay uh so this these are the
results that i
obtained earlier and they are somewhat
similar
so the one thing that we can definitely
conclude from this demo
is that graph sage and gat by
incorporating
the graph structure can lead to
very significant improvement to node
classification
and they also help to create a more
structured
well segmented embedding space
so yeah in this case the machine
actually learns and that's good
i i hope this demo um would motivate you
to consider applying graph neural
networks whenever you have
a graph structured data
and here is a list of resources that
help me to create this workshop
i've also attached my github repo
so feel free to take a look and
experiment yourself
yeah i believe this is the end of my
workshop
thank you very much for listening